you know this is something my wife is
pointed out to she said well men are
gonna have to stand up for themselves
but here's the problem I know how to
stand up to a man who's who's unfairly
trespassing against me and the reason I
know that is because the parameters for
my resistance are quite well-defined
which is we talk we argue we push and
then it becomes physical right like if
if we move beyond the boundaries of
civil discourse we know what the next
step is ok that's forbidden in in
discourse with women and so I don't
think that men can control crazy women I
don't they I really don't believe it I
think that they have to throw their
hands up in in in in what in in it's not
even disbelief it's that the cultural
there's no step forward that you can
take under those circumstances because
if the man is offensive enough and crazy
enough the reaction becomes physical
right away or at least the threat is
there and when men are talking to each
other in any serious manner that
underlying threat of physicality is
always there especially if it's a real
conversation and keeps the thing
civilized to some degree you know if
you're talking to a man who wouldn't
fight with you under any circumstances
whatsoever then you're talking to
someone to whom you have absolutely no
respect but I can't see any way for
example there's a there's a woman in in
Toronto who's been organizing this
movement let's say against me and some
other people who are gonna do a free
speech event and she managed to organize
quite effectively and she's quite
offensive you might say she compared us
to Nazis for example which you know
publicly using the swastika which wasn't
really something I was all that far in
depth but I I'm defenseless against that
kind of female insanity because the
techniques that I would use against a
man who was employing those tactics are
forbidden to me so I don't know like it
seems to me that it isn't men that have
to stand up and say enough of this even
though that is what they should do it
seems to me that it's same women who
have to stand up against their crazy
sisters and say look enough of that
enough man-hating
enough pathology enough bringing
disgrace on us as a
as a gender but the problem there and
then they'll stop my little tirade is
that most of the women I know who are
saying are busy doing same things right
they're off they have their career they
have their family they're quite occupied
and they don't seem to have the time or
maybe even the interest to go after
their their crazy harpy sisters and so I
don't see any regulating force for that
that terrible femininity and it seems to
me to be invading the culture and
undermining the the masculine power of
the culture in a way that's I think
fatal